Trascrizione:
Se vi chiedessi qual è la cosa
che vi è mancata di più, nell'ultimo anno,
probabilmente riceverei
una risposta plebiscitaria:
la vostra libertà.
E in effetti abbiamo accettato, sopportato
restrizioni alle libertà personali
senza precedenti,
nella nostra storia repubblicana.
Una forzata reclusione domestica;
una relazionalità ferita, amputata,
lontano da affetti, amici;
il coprifuoco, le frontiere sbarrate;
le scuole e le attività
economiche interrotte.
Eppure, se ci guardiamo intorno,
vediamo che la libertà manca ovunque.
Se prestiamo attenzione,
possiamo sentire le urla
o i sussurri degli oppressi
anche nella vecchia Europa:
Polonia, Ungheria.
e poi Russia, Turchia,
Egitto, Cina, Myanmar:
l'elenco è incompleto.
Il mondo brucia.
Oggi, i paesi del mondo pienamente liberi
sono meno della metà.
Soltanto il 20 percento
della popolazione del pianeta
è veramente libera.
La vedete in verde.
In Medio Oriente, in nord Africa,
più dell'80% della popolazione
vive sotto regimi
che non riconoscono pienamente
i diritti civili e la libertà politica.
Nell'Africa subsahariana,
soltanto il nove percento
della popolazione
vive in democrazie compiute.
E le cose peggiorano, anziché migliorare.
Ogni anno il numero dei paesi
che arretrano nel garantire
le libertà fondamentali
è maggiore del numero
dei paesi che avanzano.
La libertà, insomma, continua a mancarci,
e noi continuiamo
ostinatamente a cercarla.
È un'Odissea, la storia
della nostra libertà,
un cammino lungo e tortuoso
compiuto nella storia millenaria
della civiltà umana
in cui la libertà ha assunto
sembianze anche molto diverse.
Si comincia nel mito,
con Prometeo
che ruba il fuoco agli dei
per donarlo agli uomini,
e per questo gesto subisce
la punizione di Zeus
che lo fa incatenare a una roccia
ai confini del mondo,
nudo, esposto alle intemperie,
con un'aquila che gli squarcia il petto
e che ritorna ogni giorno
per divorargli il fegato
che gli ricresce durante la notte.
Ma Prometeo è un semidio,
figlio di un titano,
gli dei più antichi, che esistevano
anche prima degli dei dell'Olimpo.
E io ho sempre avuto
la sensazione, insomma,
che questa storia fosse
un regolamento di conti fra dei,
sempre così prodighi
di dispetti, invidie, rappresaglie.
Ma di certo, Prometeo
è il simbolo della ribellione,
della sfida alle imposizioni,
e alle autorità.
Eppure, quando gli uomini
sono in grado di sapere,
grazie al fuoco donato da Prometeo,
la prima cosa che sanno
è il dolore e la morte.
Perché vivere, se si deve morire?
E come liberarsi di questa condanna?
Ci viene in aiuto Epicuro.
Il significato del suo nome,
in greco antico, è proprio questo:
compagno, alleato, soccorritore.
Siamo nel quarto secolo a.C.
ed Epicuro sostiene
che il sommo bene
sia da ricercare nel piacere:
ogni nostra azione deve essere volta
a fuggire il dolore.
E pretende di liberarci
dalla paura della morte
constatando, con una logica implacabile,
che quando la morte sopraggiunge,
il corpo cessa di esistere;
se c'è la morte,
non ci siamo noi a dolercene.
Lucrezio, nella Roma
del primo secolo a.C.,
è un seguace dell'epicureismo,
ma le sue certezze vacillano.
La sua opera è pervasa
da un'ansia di liberazione,
ma, allo stesso tempo,
da una profonda angoscia esistenziale,
perché vede la fragilità
degli esseri umani.
È celebre la sua metafora
della condizione umana,
come quella di un naufrago
gettato sulle rive del mare,
solo, senza difese,
che come un bambino strappato alla madre
può soltanto farsi sentire
con i suoi vagiti disperati,
che sono il presagio
dei mille mali futuri.
La nostra è una natura di schiavi, dunque.
Però c'è stato chi si è ribellato:
lo schiavo per eccellenza, un gladiatore.
Spartaco, alla fine del mondo antico,
ritiene insopportabile
la sua condizione priva di libertà
e si metta alla testa
dell'insurrezione dei gladiatori,
che daranno del filo da torcere
addirittura a Roma,
il simbolo massimo del potere.
Ai primi e pochi ribelli
si aggiungono centinaia, migliaia
di schiavi liberati lungo la penisola
e diventano un esercito
di briganti e di clandestini.
Si abbandonano a ogni sorta di violenza,
saccheggiano, incendiano i villaggi:
è una lunga scia di sangue.
Perché Spartaco vuole andare a Roma,
è accecato dalla sete di vendetta.
Vuole far lottare nell'arena
i patrizi catturati
con i gladiatori, quelli veri,
seduti sugli spalti
a godersi lo spettacolo.
Sappiamo come andò a finire,
a migliaia verranno trucidati
dalle legioni di Crasso,
inviate dal Senato,
e crocifissi lungo la via Appia
tra Capua e Roma,
come monito del potere, a futura memoria.
Se non c'era libertà nell'antichità,
la tradizione cristiana
ci dà la speranza della redenzione,
ma il paradiso è così lontano,
nell'aldilà ultraterreno!
Qui, sulla terra, la schiavitù si perpetua
nel peccato, nell'asservimento ai tiranni.
Ma se la libertà è riposta nell'aldilà,
c'è bisogno di una rivolta metafisica:
si impugnano le armi del pensiero.
Compare sulla scena Cartesio,
e inaugura la filosofia moderna.
È la rivolta dell'intelletto,
cogito ergo sum:
come essere liberi,
se non siamo liberi di pensare?
E si inaugura il metodo scientifico,
che deve liberarci dall'errore
e dalle false credenze
che ci riducono in cattività.
Naturalmente, le opere di Cartesio
vengono messe all'indice
dal Santo Uffizio.
C'è la caccia alle streghe;
ma ci sono anche i roghi dei libri,
non meno pericolosi
se si domanda la libertà.
Però la rivoluzione
della modernità è cominciata;
e saranno gli illuministi, dopo di lui,
a raccoglierne l'eredità
e a spingersi oltre.
Si afferma il principio della ragione,
per liberarci da ogni superstizione,
da ogni dottrina dogmatica.
Abbiamo capito che non può
esserci libertà senza verità.
Di lì al regicidio, il passo è breve:
scoppia la Rivoluzione Francese.
Nella storia, di tirannicidi
ce n'erano stati tanti:
chi può dimenticare le sorti
di Giulio Cesare alle Idi di marzo,
morto per le 23 pugnalate
inferte dai congiurati
che vogliono abbattere la dittatura?
Ma questa volta si ambisce
a un livello più sublime:
il deicidio.
Con la morte del re sul patibolo,
si vuole decretare la destituzione di Dio,
sancire il primato della giustizia terrena
sulla grazia divina.
Il diritto naturale
sostituisce il diritto divino.
Ogni essere umano ha una dignità
in quanto essere umano;
ogni individuo nasce libero,
siamo tutti cittadini.
La monarchia lascia il posto
alla repubblica,
e con la democrazia del popolo
si spezzano le catene
del dispotismo dell'antico regime.
Con il terrore giacobino
che segue la Rivoluzione,
la ghigliottina diventa
lo strumento della metafisica;
e, come in ogni rivoluzione,
viene il tempo delle epurazioni.
Decine di migliaia di teste tagliate.
Da conquista dell'uomo,
la ragione diventa Ragion di Stato;
e alla fine anche la testa di Robespierre,
detto l'incorruttibile,
rotola dentro una cesta
in una piazza di Parigi.
C'è allora bisogno di una nuova rivolta,
in nome della libertà.
Il marchese De Sade
prende la questione molto sul serio:
ispira i libertini,
in questo caso la parola è tutto.
Si sostiene che la libertà di un individuo
non può conoscere alcun limite,
né virtù o vincolo morale
di tipo universale.
Anche la blasfemia è consentita,
anche il sacrilegio, la bestemmia,
l'incesto, l'omicidio,
senza doverne rispondere.
Più tardi ci sarà anche
una rivolta estetica nell'arte,
che si incarna, si fa persona
con la figura del dandy.
Baudelaire fu il poeta
più grande del suo tempo:
pubblicò un solo libro di poesie,
"I fiori del male",
ma quando comparve la sua opera
in prosa, "I paradisi artificiali",
beh, si capì il desiderio
di fuga nell'assenzio,
il rifugio dolce nell'oppio,
per negare il mondo
che ci è dato in sorte,
costruirne uno artefatto,
un mondo fatto di bellezza.
A un certo punto
Baudelaire scrive questa frase -
non è un verso, si trova
nei suoi diari intimi -
che è bellissima:
"Le tenebre verdi, nelle sere umide
della bella stagione".
Non c'è un verbo, ma è piena di movimento.
Sono tre coppie
di sostantivi e di aggettivi,
"Le tenebre verdi, nelle sere umide
della bella stagione".
È piena di drammaticità:
ma, allo stesso tempo,
anche di una sorta
di quiete nella bellezza.
Ma quella di Baudelaire
è una voluttà triste,
romantica e decadente.
Il vero interprete, sul piano filosofico,
della Rivoluzione Francese
sta in Germania: è Hegel.
L'idealismo tedesco è propriamente
filosofia della libertà,
come affermano i suoi stessi profeti.
In una lettera indirizzata a Hegel,
l'amico filosofo Schelling scrive,
"L'alfa e l'omega di tutta
la filosofia è la libertà".
Hegel dice: "Il senso
di cui siamo alla ricerca
non è proiettato nell'aldilà,
non è fuori dalla nostra portata.
Il senso si fa nella Storia,
di cui noi stessi siamo gli artefici".
E c'è un personaggio,
contemporaneo di Hegel,
che incarna alla perfezione
questo pensiero:
è Napoleone.
Il quale, di origini
tutt'altro che nobili,
sembra dire al popolo:
"Guardate me, fate come me.
Chiunque, anche il più umile,
grazie al merito può avere successo
e diventare un eroe".
È ciò che ci si vuole sentir dire,
è il nuovo mito della borghesia
nata sulle barricate della Rivoluzione.
Il popolo desidera
l'uguaglianza delle opportunità,
anche al prezzo della libertà.
Napoleone, infatti,
si incorona imperatore:
adieu alla Repubblica.
L'eredità del pensiero di Hegel
verrà raccolta da Marx,
il quale sostiene
che tutti i filosofi, prima di lui,
si sono limitati a contemplare il mondo,
ma in realtà, si tratta di cambiarlo!
Lui vuole instaurare
il regno della libertà sulla Terra;
e per lui libertà significa innanzitutto
liberazione dalla schiavitù
dei bisogni materiali, economici:
un obiettivo da raggiungere nell'avvenire,
dove è attesa una società senza classi
in cui ognuno sarà libero e uguale.
La fede nella provvidenza divina
è diventata la fede nel progresso.
Guardate, rischierò di sembrare
provocatorio o paradossale,
ma anche il capitalismo
tende verso quello stesso obiettivo:
l'incremento del potere d'acquisto
dei ceti subalterni, tutti consumisti.
Solo che in questo caso la fede è riposta
nella mano invisibile del mercato.
Ancora oggi si sfidano il capitalismo
liberale e liberista dell'Occidente
e il capitalismo politico
della Cina post-comunista.
Negli ultimi 30 anni, il Pil della Cina
è aumentato di 14 volte.
L'aspettativa di vita
è aumentata da 69 a 77 anni.
È stato drasticamente ridotto
il tasso di mortalità infantile:
da 42 a sette ogni 1000 nati.
La popolazione che vive
sotto la soglia di povertà
era pari a due terzi
del totale, 30 anni fa;
appena lo 0,5% oggi.
Il tasso di iscrizione all'università
è aumentato dal 3% al 51%;
e con l'accesso di massa ai consumi,
anche in quel paese si è stratificata
una solida classe media.
Progressi straordinari
conseguiti in un arco di tempo
veramente circoscritto,
brevissimo, soltanto 30 anni.
Ma la Cina è un regime,
autoritario e illiberale.
La crescita economica,
e il miglioramento
delle condizioni sociali,
non sono necessariamente correlati
con un maggiore grado di libertà.
Ma allora a cosa serve la libertà,
se una società può stare meglio
anche senza essere libera?
La nostra tormentata ricerca
deve continuare,
se poi non fosse arrivato
quel dottor Freud
a complicare ancora di più le cose.
Sigmund Freud, lo scopritore
dell'inconscio,
che ha svelato l'oscurità
che è presente dentro di noi,
le forze invisibili
che si agitano nella mente,
i traumi, le rimozioni, i tabù.
Che ci imprigionano,
e non ci permettono di essere liberi.
E ci mancava pure il dottor Freud,
come se non avessimo già abbastanza guai.
L'algebra della libertà
diventa ancora più complicata.
Tuttavia nulla, niente può scoraggiare
quel desiderio di libertà
che avvertiamo nel nostro cuore,
e in nome del quale abbiamo compiuto
le mille rivoluzioni che ho raccontato.
Ma sapete qual è il significato originario
della parola latina "revolutio"?
Significa ritorno.
Infatti, in geometria
la rivoluzione è il moto di rotazione
intorno a un asse immobile;
e in astronomia, il movimento
di un corpo celeste
intorno al suo centro di gravitazione,
come la rivoluzione terrestre
intorno al sole
o quella della luna intorno alla Terra.
Ecco, la nostra rivoluzione
in nome della libertà
è allora un ritorno.
Ma un ritorno a cosa?
Un ritorno a ciò che si è veramente,
un ritorno a quello che siamo
nel senso più autentico,
cioè, evidentemente,
a quello che non siamo ancora diventati.
"Come si diventa ciò che si è?"
si domandava un altro
grande filosofo, Nietzsche.
Noi siamo spesso insoddisfatti,
inquieti, scontenti
per quello che non siamo,
per quello che non abbiamo.
Perché, questo è il punto,
noi siamo in grado
di pensarlo, quel "non":
quello che non siamo,
quello che non abbiamo.
Questa, naturalmente,
è una vera dannazione,
il motivo per il quale ci rammarichiamo,
siamo così spesso inquieti.
Ma è anche una sbalorditiva opportunità,
perché ci dice che noi viviamo
nel dominio della possibilità,
del non ancora realizzato,
in un caleidoscopio di destini personali
che desta tutta la nostra meraviglia.
E allora, in un tempo in cui
lo spirito critico sembra
annegare nel conformismo,
forse la libertà
è proprio questo equilibrio,
continuamente perduto e ritrovato,
mentre noi camminiamo,
come dei funamboli innamorati della vita,
sulla corda tesa tra l'errore e la verità,
tra ciò che sembriamo
e ciò che ci sentiremo liberi di essere,
senza più costruirci falsi alibi,
senza più tradire noi stessi,
allora sì, vedremo un cuore
veramente messo al nudo,
colmo di tutto il nostro furore di vivere
e dei nostri 3000 anni
di storia e di filosofia
che abbiamo nelle vene.
.(Applausi)